no reasonable person can deny that Dr
Harmons was a difficult situation
an impossible situation
but we're not here
to second guess what he didn't do or
should have done we're here because of
what he actually did
imagine thinking oh my God my child
might commit mass murder what would you
do
I've never seen anything quite like this
particular episode of television what do
you do when there's nothing you can do
that situation really kind of became the
Genesis I read the script with no
intention of doing this and then when I
read it I had to do it
Howard has just told this story in all
its Shades of Gray I just got to explore
that I think intimately and powerfully
and I think humanly and I think as human
beings we have a tendency towards denial
every time you decide to pay attention
to him you start to catastrophone well
every time you make excuses and point
fingers at everyone else we all wonder
why didn't the parents see it when
you're living through it you don't see
it it's very difficult for anybody to
really understand where that is coming
from you really realize how sometimes we
see just what we want to see the idea of
Devin Harding himself is horrifying what
if he hurts someone else it's a
terrifying Prospect I'll get the money
I knocked who are you talking to
since when do you care we're not done
here
I've never played anything like this and
it's excruciating place to go did Dr
Harmon ever share the cold calculus of
killing his own son before his son could
kill anyone else this is the story of
how we cope with the darkest thoughts
that we can possibly have what if he
does what I'm afraid of did Dr and share
his plan to murder him I don't know how
you could watch this and not feel
tremendous empathy for what these people
are going through the impossibility of
that situation I think really is like a
lose-lose proposition do you remember
the state park I think you'd really like
it and you're gonna say it well what
would I do and how could I prevent this
and if I'm going to play that game I
would try to connect in any way that I
could at least that's what I think I'd
do
I was talking to my friend about the
situation and he said I could go with
him on this trip that he's got planned
that's what the money's for
this is one of those things that unless
you go through it I don't think it's
possible for you to really know what you
do
Park here and come with me
your son wants to talk to you
everyone wants to be right and we're
often not right Dr Harmon hadn't given
Devin ten thousand dollars but you and
he have been able to carry out the
shooting not a chance it's a giant what
if but very timely and very relevant you
want to reach people and this piece of
material reached me I thought this is
something that could stir people move
them and get them talking
foreign
[Music]